after a long to round day we have
entered the home stretch of the 2013 st.
Louis classic only three players total
can still earn a norm and just one of
them is likely to do so in the sixth
round international master priyadarshan
one with black against the former front
runner of the GM field Roger panjwani
well this is my close second close
tournament last year was the first storm
of last year st. Louis GM imitation was
my first close tournament invitation
other than that I played many open
tournaments with GM norm possibilities
but never made a GM wrong so far I moved
three in the opening at late night dee
Ford this is a very rare line which
threw him a bit off of his preparation I
bill I believe and then after that we
got a fairly standard English position
except why didn't have the knight on f3
and black didn't have the night on CC
because we exchanged it after that his
Queen was bit misplaced as I don't move
18 on waiting he paid after I which was
a very interesting exchange sacrifice it
was a very dynamic one and it looked
like blah White had enough compensation
for his exchange sacrifice but he must
24 Bishop h8 normal more than he missed
I would say it was see it was a force
continuation that position that that's
the only move which keeps advantage for
black or some sort of pressure and I
found that move and then the
consecutively I found 25 route g7 though
it looks a bit scary to play Duke g7 I /
61 is very weak and there's like not a
lot of tactics like 97 for possibly but
after that like he he realized that
white a black is slightly better and
that I think [ __ ] made him lose his
motivation or I believe because his his
most were not up to the mark after that
point and
31 d forgave me 31 d 4 was a blunder i
would say because it gave me a chance to
play h by an open apis open up the
position if it's closed i would have
been really tough for me too Oh like
capitalize on my exchange up to n to win
the game so after h5 I was exchanged and
upon up which really helped me to LA to
a kia place on my advantage after it was
not a big deal because my peers all
became active so the material advantage
became a huge factor and after that was
just like had no problem and winning
that game and look who's leading the
pack it's John Bartholomew who is on a
roll in this tournament with three
rounds left he's on track to earn his
first Grand Master norm in the IM field
feed a master Shan vilbert had a great
day he went 2 and 0 Sean explains how he
took advantage early against a wonder
lang in the sixth pretty good event for
me so far I I actually started out
pretty badly I had a half out of three
and my parents were like off playing so
badly and I said how about this I win
the rest and I get nyam norm you have to
eat those words and they're like okay
fine with me so i have i've won three in
a row now three and a half out of seven
huge comeback and my next players are a
bit easier in my previous ones so it
started off and sicilian time enough or
some other countries something else
starts e6 and around this point in the
game house feeling pretty good because i
know from the start that in these
positions white needs to go Bishop to e3
and Queen d2 and long side castle or the
game's pretty easy for blacks what I
know but throughout them this is hiep
chose the second line which is this one
it's okay it's pretty even but at this
point in the game I think he forgot the
opening it was extremely pivotal this
movie made I think literally puts him
down to 23 tempos Bishop d3 i'm not sure
why he did it maybe he wanted to protect
efore but i think it's just because he's
got forgotten affair and he was thinking
of a different line now Bishop d7
prepares
for c5 to c4 and after that black just
looks golden almost winning now he may
have been okay if he had may be played f
for now and maybe Queen f3 and then I'd
get c4 in and he moves back maybe I
could have been equal position i guess
but he moved to Bishop to g5 now this
move probably is whenever the game
totally changed in blacks favor after
Bishop g5 I don't see much reasoning
behind it me will probably want to get
rid the F night to protect the epon we
can do that by other means now
essentially his dark squared Bishop is
best the ship on the board is going away
and I'll have the entire advantage so c5
like I said planning c4 and is out note
say about his position almost looks
losing so rookie one which probably is
the best move I didn't see it at the
time it protects the e pawn and prepares
for Bishop f1 so whenever he's going to
take my F night yes for taking g2 still
though it's pretty tough I play see for
this ship f1 now Bishop d6 I thought
about the smooth for a while as I had a
lot of moves here to play but I decided
that going for the b4 idea with the
bishop on e5 is best so h3 h3 may have
been probably what sealed the deal here
after after h3 pretty much weakens his
King side to the G file allows my bishop
to stay where it is and more importantly
he didn't activate his light squared
Bishop if he was to go g3 now I think
I'm still a lot better here but after
moves like this and what to say for him
I guess probably since I'm threatening
this takes maybe takes with the Jeep
gone yeah Jeep on he kind of has a bit
of better position than he just had
maybe yes defend here but still it looks
pretty grim but having Bishop g2
probably was his last hope you after
that there's not much else for him so be
four Bishop takes he has to or else he
loses the heap on G takes
night be one I guess there's not much
else you can do not on a force pretty
weak c3 now I had to make this move I
don't go see three gets c3 and himself
and there's not much after that pretty
much has a solid position that it's not
great but he might be able to hold him
so c3b text only move or else the night
gets trapped rook d8 threatening the
Queen Queen f3 Bishop to e5 at this
point I don't know he'd have to play
perfectly like an engine survive but not
much else to it Bishop d3 f5 now this I
had considered this for a while
positionally my positions much better
but I was looking at the end games or
his night would get to see for after all
this shenanigans to the right was gone
and I wasn't really seeing much winning
chances I knew there was a lot i had but
i thought i'd have to do something
drastic especially since he was low on
time to about 20 minutes at this point i
thought i'd go for it f5 queen e 2
probably one of the only moves getting
out of the pin Queen c6 continuing the
pin and also protecting hey six Knight
d2 which I don't know if he should have
played it or not I guess it doesn't
change much he had f3 here and now f4
and I guess it transposes after this but
still he may not have bet he may not
wanted to move there and maybe protected
his King better so 92 takes rook 81 only
move then rook GA so just adding the
pressure and not doing any decisive
moves so we'll lose on time at three f4
at this point in the game I'd say it's
probably lost for what there's
absolutely no way for him to protect the
G attack especially since his IV five
coming I guess if he had any hope here
it would definitely had to have been g4
immediately if he doesn't go g4 he's in
the world of hurt because this attack is
devastating now if on basant King g2
I mean I know it's losing probably
because the h3 pawn and my pieces are
just playing better but still he might
have hope here but besides that he moved
king h1 I go 'if i probably for the
attack still he has g3 but it's not as
good now because his Kings already moved
to h1 he loses a tempo so rook f1
getting out of the pin the movies night
rook g3 night be three now I have a
sacrifice coming on h3 gel show goes
after Bishop c8 and thought oh I'll just
make a random move for him to waste some
time to show what it is after Bishop
takes pawn takes rook check looks like
i'm down a minor piece but actually win
after king here i can go Queen g6 in
which i have checkmate the next move no
matter what tricking here it's checkmate
and after king here sorry the mouse
after King here but it would be
checkmate so nothing you could do in
that line now Bishop c4 makes sense the
only thing you can do is try to trade I
take rook takes Bishop takes h3 there's
no way to stop this he has lots of
variations here such as moving his king
but if he was to move his King now I
could just take and I win this bishop so
the endgame is winning so he decides to
go night a 5 attacking my queen now
there's lots of stuff that he can do
like for example knight on c6 or Bishop
b5 but every single move after this is
countered immediately because i have
bishop moving checking and discover
check wins whatever he attacks me with
so at this point IRA's ein with about 1
minute 30 seconds left on the clock both
Sean vivir and Seth Houma are still
trekking on for their norms but remember
most of the players are still able to
place and win prize money after all that
has been the goal of the top titled
players from the very start the second
annual classic goes through the 27th as
we wait to see who will make a
breakthrough performance subscribe to
our YouTube channel and view the games
at us chess champs calm